d'après cette étude si je faisais
moins de lessive et moins de vaisselle nous
aurions plus de relations sexuelles les femmes sont moins susceptibles de
vouloir baiser le mec si elles gagnent
plus d'argent donc nous aimons qu'un couple sexy
soit voulez-vous prendre votre
Enlève ton manteau et reste un
moment  ton petit bébé à mâcher
si senorita oh mon dieu je ne pense pas
pouvoir bouger nous avons 15 ans de relation
il a eu comme je l'ai fait une mauvaise carte
[Musique]
ça doit être à peu près plus que ça je
ne veux pas baiser  toi il manque quelque chose d'
autre bonjour tu es en train de faire je suis
un ouvrier du bâtiment alors pourquoi est-ce que je
répare ton évier
avec eux c'est la différence
entre le café et ma vodka
[Musique]